uh wizards of waverly place on the
disney channel how old were you got that
17 17 and that ultimately changed your
life changed my life the best them
i don't know what i i mean i hope i'd
still be in the industry but it gave me
the opportunity to be in the united
states so
you know peter marietta and gary marsh
at disney channel and especially judy
taylor who sort of
had a general meeting with me in the us
when i was on holiday here
took a liking to me and then worked so
hard to create basically they kind of
created that role in wizards for me
although they
definitely didn't tell me that because
they still made me audition um
but you know they created sort of that
role for me and i'm
so grateful because it allowed me to get
my visa
um disney channel sponsored it which was
incredible
and it was just
and then to get not just get a job but
to get a job on extremely well written
show um some would argue probably the
best disney channel show ever written in
the sense of not just people love that
show yeah and then
selena gomez obviously who's
incredible well who's that yeah exactly
yeah so she completely blew up and then
to have a storyline to play selena's
boyfriend
it was just like
one of those like wow this kind of
happened to me moments
because
she was so successful the show was the
show was becoming so popular already
already was at the time just won an emmy
so i sort of it was literally the right
time right place right character right
storyline right co-star did you have an
english accent in that in english you
had an english accent but then you
started veering away from that and a lot
of projects now
like pretty smart yeah you you you do
away with that yeah you just have an
american accent yeah i think what
happened was when i first got into the
states i was you know i was obviously
practicing my dialect and then disney
channel i booked an
i booked an nbc pilot
um after i'd recovered on wizard
and
like during like after like four or five
months of being in the united states i
had booked an nbc pilot and i remember
my
the pilot
it wasn't the best pilot in the world i
would do a lot of those so my manager
who i'm still with today
good for you my manager i'm still with
uh was like okay
this i'm gonna now teach you about
leverage and so went back to disney i
went back to disney channel and said
okay he's gonna not be on the show and
at the time my character was extremely
loved
and they didn't want to lose that
storyline and so disney channel put me
under a two picture deal
uh and guaranteed me i can't remember
the exact amount of episodes on the show
but that secured basically a
relationship over two years or three
years with the disney channel